[Musik]
wir gehen rauf auf dem Server hast du
noch gar nicht meinen Teppich da genauer
angeschaut Luca super Teppich das sind
einfach zwei Bodenplatten da nein das
ist ein Teppich da kann man drüber
laufen das ist gut das reinigt die
Schuhe hä
was passiert
[Musik]
ich werde auf jeden Fall nachher noch
ein Zombie zusammen locken ich habe eine
Idee lass dich gleich mal überraschen
was ich hier wieder vor habe nur wenige
Minuten später komm jetzt rein was hast
du gemacht schön
ein Traum aus Blumen hey Luca Das bist
DU geistig bist du geistig Leute es kann
schon sein dass er jetzt hier raus geht
theoretisch und verpiss dich dahin ins
Wasser und das weg
[Musik]
die läuft immer weg die schwarze Katze
hahaha wir haben sich Katzen
[Musik]
Luca ich sterbe gerade
so Leute Name für die Katze was sagt ihr
[Musik]
haben sogar noch einen Ofen hier guck
ich stelle in dein Haus dann kannst du
dir selber Glas machen hier vorne Sand
oben rein und Kohle unten
irgendwie ist mein Sand weg ich habe
mein Sand da reingelegt das war es ist
weg jetzt hä manchmal spinnt das aber
auch wenn man den Ofen guckt und dann
schaut man muss man einmal wieder
rausgehen
[Musik]
ja jetzt geht's
innerhalb von einer Minute killst ist
gleich 100
€. ich würde gerne wissen wie unsere
Insel davor aussah
weißt du warum ich dich gerade getötet
habe warum mir hat jemand gesagt wenn
ich dich jetzt töte kriegen wir 100 €
[Musik]
100 Euro
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mein PC ist glaube ich abgestürzt
oh kann sein dass du einmal einfach vom
Server rausgehen musst
und jetzt musst du wieder rauf kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Kuss der ist für dich
[Musik]
ey das ist doch irre ihr seid doch
wirklich nicht mehr zu retten leute
danke schön wirklich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist doch nicht mehr normal ja oder
heißt du denn überhaupt ja du hast mir
immer noch nicht geschrieben wie du
heißt
[Musik]
ich habe mich gerade mal gemütet damit
Sandra dass ihr nicht hört die wird
komplett ausrasten aber nicht danke für
99 Euro ey Leute chillt also wenn ich
mich entscheiden muss zwischen sauer und
süß würde ich sagen
danke schön
[Musik]
danke ey das ist so simpel das Spiel
eigentlich ich habe es jetzt gerollt ja
also man wird auch noch andere Sachen
lernen wie man andere Sachen craftet
das Handy ist Range Rover
[Musik]
und hier steht keiner weil du keinen
hast oder wie
ich schaue Dich schon seit einer halben
Ewigkeiten
wann kommt der nächste Stream warst du
schon mal in Kassel
[Musik]
in den Ofen rein Alter dann habe ich
wenigstens leckeres Steak Alter bin und
Leute was geht hier ab könnt ihr bitte
klarkommen mit den Spenden ja cool
die hört mich gerade nicht danke danke
Enrico für 50 € Patrick danke danke
danke auch für deine Spende
[Musik]
Leute wen habe ich jetzt wen habe ich
vergessen weil VIP machen sagt das mal
bitte eben mein Pferd ist jetzt endlich
drin
[Musik]
wenn wir jetzt mal theoretisch die
Steinsäge da drauf stellen
[Musik]
ja bitte verlass diesen Stream bitte ich
kann es sein
sag als ob das ein Friedhof wäre das
hier ja kann es sein dass du dumm bist
bitte gebt euer Geld nicht für mich aus
gebt euer Geld für vernünftige Sachen
aus
es ist nicht mehr normal was hier gerade
abgeht hört jetzt auf bitte leute bitte
gebt eure Geld für vernünftige Dinge aus
was ist denn passiert erzählen die Leute
sagen ich soll dich über FaceTime
anrufen und dir
ihr sagen es ist so viel also das Handy
gerade hat noch mal also die ganze Zeit
kam so Beträge über 100 € rein und so
also wirklich mehrmals gerade dann hat
jemand aber 300 € donated
ich komme auch nicht klar
bisschen dumm ach du scheiße ich wohne
in der so fetten Villa Luca guckst du
jetzt an
sehr sehr geil bist du neidisch sei
ehrlich
ich habe jetzt meine Verbindung getrennt
ja ich mache das ja gleiche jetzt und
Sandy Kugeln Stream Ciao ja danke dass
du mit dabei warst ich schicke Dir jetzt
noch mal eben hier 2 € für deine Cola
Zero und die 50 € von Dings
danke
tschüss tschüss zusammen
die Sache ist jetzt nur bleibt das jetzt
bis Sandra das nächste Mal auf dem
Server ist halt das Ding
sie will schlafen gehen und sie kann
nicht schlafen weil Monster in der Nähe
sind ja die Spawn du brauchst ein Name
Tag es reicht ein Boot okay
so jetzt klappt oder es waren sehr sehr
sehr geiler Minecraft Stream hat mir
sehr viel Spaß gemacht
[Musik]